Speaker 1: The The David Pakman Show subreddit
is approaching 34000 subscribers, which is
its the most subscribed David Pakman
show subreddit in the world. In fact,
that's that's true. It's a meaningless
statement, but it is true. David
Pakman dot com slash Reddit A few interesting
posts I spotted this morning. You know,
many of you know that I like to joke around about
restaurants and food related things and whatnot.
And the other day I tweeted about, you know, 90
percent jokingly, but also 10 percent seriously.
Why is all the anti-mask stuff happening at places
like Applebee's and Burger King and whatever?
And a bunch of people got mad and said, I'm being
boujee and elitist and all these different things,
but it's sort of a real question. And I
spotted a post on the subreddit from User
Collega three, who said, David, this is why
Applebee's exists despite sucking. David,
you're right to be baffled that the
existence, let alone popularity of Applebee's
because know their food is not anything special,
nor is it cheap. That's an important thing.
Applebee's isn't cheap. You're able to see it that
way because like me, you are not an alcoholic.
That is the key to success for these crappy chains
like Applebee's, Chili's, Ruby Tuesdays to give
Fridays, etc. The word grill is a dog whistle for
people who want to get drunk more than they want
to eat, but need to keep up appearances.
So rather than go to a bar or a liquor
store where the goal is obvious, they can go
somewhere and order food. They'll barely touch
to avoid buzz killing and flood themselves with
beer, a margarita or whatever. Whatever. I've
learned this from a lifetime of having closeted
alcoholic friends, and when I would suggest we
go to a restaurant for its wonderful food
if they didn't serve booze, friends would
think of some excuse not in the mood for whatever
and suggest one of these putrid chains instead.
A very interesting fact is that even God-Fearing
dry counties can be bought by these corporate
booze troughs via the Local Chamber of Commerce.
I used to live in Conway, Arkansas, which is dry.
Wow, that's crazy. And as far back as I knew,
the only way to get drunk was drive to the next
county for their liquor stores or be a member
of the VFW club. Oh, there's another thing you
don't have young children. Grills always have
a kids menu so you can kill two birds with one
stone shut. The brats faces up with dinosaur chip
shaped chicken nuggets or whatever. Drink yourself
stupid and then drive home. This is very on
point, and I don't think I have much of a
comment other than I continue to be completely
against the concept of a kids menu for in my
mind. And if I have kids and I go against this,
you can all troll me and my mind. Kids menu means
what the adults are eating, but a smaller portion.
If I go back on that at some point in the future,
you all have the right to make fun of me. Another
interesting post from the David Pakman show
subreddit from Samael. Major serious question.
Are there any prominent left wing self-help
figures? This is a good topic there May and Samael
writes. There may be a ton and I'm oblivious. But
when I scan my media landscape, the types of
people that mix in self-help talk and ideas
most frequently are people like Jordan Peterson,
Joe Rogan and Jocko Willink. Figures like Louis
Rosman, who ostensibly has a channel themed around
repairs but wades into life lessons. He's learned,
and he's a libertarian bro. These kinds of figures
seem so numerous on the right. Enjoy talking about
their experiences and how others can avoid
their pitfalls and help themselves and again,
where are the people offering this life advice who
are on the left? I've seen David do it, but rarely
seems more of a sense and focus on systems
and less of a focus on the individual.
I know that's a basic difference between left
and right frames. The most left wing person I'm
aware of that goes into experiences
and lessons is ironically destiny.
Yeah. So I have a couple, a couple of thoughts
on this. First of all, is Deepak Chopra left
wing like, I think Deepak Chopra is a total
pseudoscience charlatan. A thousand percent.
But is is he sort of considered left wing? He's
like in the woo woo left. But that's just one
thought I have. But I think that what may be
at play here is it's less about sort of one
aspect is the concept of self-help. Is based
around the individual rather than systems,
it's how do you act to help yourself? The if
self-help were to be about changing systems,
it's less about self because it's not a thing.
It's not about what one individual can really do.
So by its nature, self-help is going to
be based on what can you do for yourself,
either in actions or in that reorienting? You're
thinking about things. But there's another aspect
I think that skews the self-help world outside
of the woo woo away from the left, which is
leftists I believe are less interested in the
idea of here is a person who has the answers.
There's an aspect of when we look at I've talked
about left wing cult of personality, a little
bit like there has been a cult of personality to
some degree around Bernie. That doesn't mean every
Bernie supporter is part of the cult understand.
There was certainly a cult of personality around
Andrew Yang tools, although I don't think she's
really on the left. There was a very big cult
of personality around her, but for the most part,
if your idea is this one person has the answers,
that's the right wing idea that the Trump
literally said it. Only I can fix it and his
followers fell for it. People like, you know, Tony
Robbins, who my understanding is certainly skews
right or Jordan Peterson and all these others.
Part of it is you have to believe that one
person has the solutions and the answers, and
that is an idea in my experience that appeals
more to the right than the left. So I think I
think that that's a part of it as well. One last
post I spotted days were Ver wants to get the
O.G. David Pakman theme music back on the show.
Here's the problem I don't know which is the
O.G. theme music, so I will consider changing
the theme music, but you've got to email me with
a link to the theme music you're talking about,
and in all seriousness, I will consider it.
But you've got to let me know which theme
music you're referring to. Join the discussion
on Reddit at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit.